a chess robot in moscow made
international headlines in an exhibition
last week but not for good reasons it
broke a seven-year-old boy's finger
mid-game while playing the robot a
repurposed industrial robot was playing
three games simultaneously and caught
the boy's finger while he was reaching
for a piece
four men were needed to free the boy who
remained remarkably composed throughout
and eventually finished the tournament
though while wearing a cast
the chess robot has been active for more
than a decade playing games against
chess legends like alexander grishock
and vladimir kramnik and always having a
positive impression up until now despite
intimidating the opposing players
the moscow chess federation drew
criticism for their statement on the
matter which appeared to lay the blame
on the boy for failing to follow the set
safety procedures and beginning his next
move before the robot had finished its
move